[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من العاصمه
السودانيه التي تتواصل فيها وفي مدنها
ثلاث اشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع معدويه متواصل لاسلحه ثقيله صادر
من شمال ام درمان
الى باريس حيث اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه ان
فرنسا علقت جميع مساعداتها التنمويه
للنيجر والدعم الذي تقدمه للميزانيه على
الفور
والى واشنطن وتقرير تقول فيه نيويورك
تايمز ان اداره بايدن تبحث عن فيروس صيني
يستهدف البنى التحتيه في القواعد العسكريه
الامريكيه في العالم
[موسيقى]
ننتقل مباشره الى تطوان شمال المغرب هو
خطاب للعاهل المغربي الملك محمد السادس
بمناسبه عيد العرش
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على مولانا رسول الله
واله وصحبه شعبي العزيز
لقد انعم الله تعالى على بلادنا
للتلاحم الدائم والتجاوب التلقائي بين
العرش والشعب
وهو ما مكان المغرب من اقامه دوله امه
تضرب جذورها في اعماق التاريخ
واننا نحمده تعالى على ما انعم به علينا
من عونه وتوفيقه حيث تمكنا من تحقيق
العديد من المنجزات ومن مواجهه الصعوبات
والتحديات
والمغاربه معروفون والحمد لله
اخصال الصدق والتفاؤل وبالتسامح والانفتاح
والاعتزاز بتقاليدهم العريقه وبنهويه
الوطنيه الموحده
والمغاربه معروفون على الخصوص بالجديه
والتفاني في العمل
واليوم وقد وصل مسارنا التنموي الى درجه
من التقدم والنضج
فاننا في حاجه الى هذه الجديه
لالتقاء به الى مرحله جديده
وفتح افاق اوسع من الاصلاحات والمشاريع
الكبرى التي يستحقها المغاربه
شاميه العزيز
انما ندعو اليه ليس شعارا فارغا او مجرد
قيمه سوريه وانما هو مفهوم متكامل يشمل
مجموعه من المبادئ العمليه والقيم
الانسانيه
فكلما كانت الجديه حافزنا كلما نجحنا في
تجاوز الصعوبات ورفع التحديات
فالشباب المغربي متى توفرت له الظروف
وتسلح بالجد وبروح الوطنيه دائما ما يبهر
العالم بانجازات كبيره وغير مسبوقه فتلك
التي حققها المنتخب الوطني في كاس العالم
فقد قدم ابناؤنا بشهاده الجميع وطنيا
ودوليا اجمل صوره حب الوطن
والوحده والوحده والتفاؤل والتلاحم
العائلي والشعبي واثار مشاعر الفخر
والاهتزاز لدينا ولد كل مقوينات الشعب
المغربي
وهي نفس الروح التي كانت وراء اقرارنا
بتقديم ملف ترشيح المشترك مع اصدقائنا في
اسبانيا والبرتغال لاحتضان نهايتك كاس
العالم لكره القدم 2030 والتي نتطلع ونعمل
على ان تكون تاريخيه على جميع المستويات
انه ترشيح غير مسبوق يجمع بين قارتين
وحضارتين افريقيا واوروبا ويوحد ضيفتي
البحر الابيض المتوسط ويحمل طموحات
وتطلعات شعب المنطقه الشعوب المنطقه
للمزيد من التعاون والتواصل والتفاهم
وتتجلى جديه كذلك في مجال الابداع
والابتكار الذي يتميز به الشباب المغربي
في مختلف المجالات
واخص بالاشاده هنا
انتاج اول سياره في المغربيات محليه الصنع
بكفاءات وطنيه وتمويل مغربي وكذا تقديم
اول نموذج لسياره تعمل بالهيدروجين قام
بتطويرها شاب مغربي
وهي مشاريع تؤكد النبوغ المغربي والثقافي
طاقات
وقدرات وقدرات شبابنا
وتشجعه على المزيد من الاجتهاد والابتكار
وتعزز علامه صنع بالمغرب
وتقوي مكانه بلادنا كوجهه للاستثمار
المنتج كما تتجسد الجديه عندما يتعلق
الامر بقضيه وحدتنا وحدتنا العربي
الترابيه
فهذه الجديان المشروعيه هي التي اثمرت
توالي الاعترافات لسياده المغرب على
اقاليمه الجنوبيه واخرها اعتراف دوله
اسرائيل وفتح القنصنيات بالعيون والداخله
والتزايد الدعم لمبادره الحكم الذاتي
وبنفس الجدي والحر والحزم نؤكد موقف
المغرب الراسخ بخصوص اداله القضيه
الفلسطينيه
والحقوق المشروعه للشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق
في اقامه دولته المستقله وعاصمتها القدس
الشرقيه بما يضمن الامن والاستقرار لجميع
شعوب المنطقه
والجديه يجب ان تظل مذهبنا في الحياه
والعمل وان تشمل جميع المجالات
الجديه في الحياه السياسيه والاداريه
والقضائيه من خلال خدمه المواطن واختيار
الكفاءات المؤهله وتغليب المصالح العليا
للوطن والمواطنين والترفع عن المزايدات
والحسابات الضيقه
وفي المجال الاجتماعي وخاصه قطاعات الصحه
والتعليم والشغل والسكن كما ان الجديه
التي نريدها تعني ايضا الفاعلين
الاقتصاديين وقطاع الاستثمار والانتاج
والعمل
والجديه كمان هذه متكامل تقتضي ربط ممارسه
مسؤوليه بالمحاسبه واشاعه قيم الحكامه
والعمل والاستحقاق وتكافؤ الفرص شعبيه
العزيز
لقد ساهمت تدعيه الازمه التي يعرفها
العالم
وتوادي سنوات الجفاف على المستوى الوطني
في ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه وتباطؤ وتيره
نمو الاقتصادي لذا وجهنا الحكومه لاتخاذ
التدابير اللازمه غزه تخفيف اثارها
السلبيه على الفئات الاجتماعيه والقطاعات
الاكثر تضررا
وضمان تزويد الاسواق المنتوجات الضروريه
واليوم مع ظهور بعض بوادر التراجع
التدريجي للضغوط التضخم على المستوى
العالمي فاننا في امس الحاجه الى جديه
واشاعه الثقه واستثمار للفرص الجديده
لتعزيز صمود وانتعاش الاقتصاد الوطني
وفي هذا الصدد
اطلقنا مشروع الاستثمار الاخضر للمكتب
الشريف للفوسفاط وقمنا بتسريع مسارق قطاع
الطاقات المتجدده
وانثى الاجتماع الذي ترى انسناه في هذا
الشهر عدت الحكومه مشروع ارض المغرب في
مجال الهيدروجين الاخضر واننا ندعوها
للاسراع لتنزيله بجوده اللازمه وبما يضمن
تمثيل تثمين المؤهلات التي تسخر بها
بلادنا والاستجابه لمشاريع المستثمرين
العالميين في هذا المجال الواعد
واستكمالا لورشه الحمايه الاجتماعيه ننتظر
المشروع نهايه هذا العام
كما كان مقررا في منح التعويضات
الاجتماعيه لفائده الاسره المستهدفه
ونامل ان يساهم هذا الدخل المباشر في
تحسين الوضع المعيشي لملايين الاسر
والاطفال الذين نحس بمعاناتهم
وستشكل هذه الخطوه ان شاء الله
ركيزه اساسيه في نموذج التنموي والاجتماعي
لصيانه كرامه المواطنين في كل ابعادها
اما في مجال تدبير الموارد المائيه التي
يتطلب المزيد من الجديه واليقظه فقد حرصنا
على بلوره البرنامج الوطني للماء لفتره
2020 2020
واننا ندعو
للتتبع الدقيق في كل مراحل تنفيذه مؤكدين
اننا لن نتساهل
مع اي شكل من اشكال سوء الحكامه والتدبير
والاستعمال الفوضوي المسؤول للماء
شعبيه العزيز
في ظل ما يعرف العالم من اهتزاز في منظومه
القيم والمرجعيات وتداخل العديد من
الازمات فاننا في اشد حاجه الى التشبت
بالجديه
بمعناها المغربي الاصيل اولا التمسك
بالكلام الدين والوطنيه
وبشعارنا الخالد الله الوطن الملك
ثانيا في التشبث بالوحده الوطنيه
والترابيه للبلاد ثالثا في صيانه الروابط
الاجتماعيه والعائليه من اجل مجتمع
المتضامن ومتماسك رابعا في مواصله مسارنا
التنموي من اجل تحقيق التقدم الاقتصادي
وتعزيز العداله الاجتماعيه
شعبي العزيز
ان عملنا على خدمه شعبنا لا يقتصر فقط على
القضايا الداخليه
وانما نحدث ايضا على اقامه علاقات وطيده
مع الدول الشقيقه والصديقه وخاصه دول
الجوار
وخلال هذه الاشهر الاخيره يتساءل العديد
من الناس العلاقات بين المغرب والجزائر
وهي علاقات مستقره تتطلع لان تكون افضل
وفي هذا الصدد يؤكد مره اخرى لاخواننا
الجزائريين قياده وشاره ان المغرب لن يكون
ابدا مصدر ايسر او سور وكذا الاهميه
البالغه التي نوليها لروابط المحبه
والصداقه والتبادل والتواصل بين شعبين
ونسال الله تعالى ان تعود الامور الى
طبيعتها ويتم فتح الحدود بين بلدينا
وشعبينا الجارين الشقيقين
الشعبيه العزيز
نقتلم هذه المناسبه ان وجدت تحيه اشهاده
وتقدير لكل مكونات قواتنا المسلحه الملكيه
والامن الوطني الملكي والقوات المساعده
والوقايه المدنيه هل تجندها الدائم تحت
قيادتنا للدفاع عن وحده الوطن وامنيه
واستقراره كما ندعو الله تعالى بالرحمه
والمغفره والرضوان لشهداء المغرب الابرار
وفي مقدمتهم جدنا ووالدنا المنعمان زالت
الملكين محمد الخامس والحصه الثاني اكرم
الله مثواهما
ونصف الختام قوله تعالى ان الذين امنوا
وعملوا الصالحات انا لا نضيع اجر من احسن
عملا صدق الله العظيم والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله اذا كان هذا الخطاب العاهل المغربي
الملك محمد السادس بمناسبه عيد العرش وفي
مواضيع الحصاد في هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
في ختام اليوم الثالث للانقلاب الاتحاد
الاوروبي وفرنسا يعلنان وقف الدعم المقدم
للنيجر واشنطن تتعهد للرئيس المعزول
باستعاده النظام وعشيه قمه طارئه للمجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا الاتحاد
الافريقي يمهل قاده الانقلاب 15 يوما
لاستعاده السلطه الدستوريه
والصدوي المتواصل للاشتباكات في ام درمان
الجيش السوداني يقول ان قواته تنفذ تمشيطا
في المدينه ويشن ضربات جويه على تجمعات
لقوات الدعم السريع الجنوبيه الخرطوم
وغداه اشتراط حميدتي تغيير قياده الجيش
للوصول الى اتفاق الخارجيه السودانيه تتهم
الدعم السريع بعدم الالتزام بما تم
التوافق عليه في جده
وصفه مبادرات متعدده للتسويه روسيا تقول
انها تلقت نحو 30 مبادره سلام بشان
اوكرانيا كيف تتمسك بخطتها لانهاء الحرب
ومع استمرار المعارك في جبهات الجنوب
والشرق
يتفقد مواقع للقوات الخاصه قرب بخموت
وفولندا تحذر مقاتل فاجنر اقتربوا اكثر من
حدودنا
منشات امريكيه في مرمى الاختراق الاداره
الامريكيه تحقق في اختراق صينيا محتمل
لشبكات طاقه ومياه واتصالات تغذي قواعد
عسكريه امريكيه في الداخل والخارج ومجله
فوربس تكشف عن تحقيق في اختراق داخلي
للاتصالات عبر سبعه عشره منشاه تابعه
للقوات الجويه الامريكيه
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا فرص وامكانيه التسويه بين
روسيا واوكرانيا في ضوء المبادرات
المتتاليه لانهاء حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في ظل
الحديث عن مبادرات سلام ما هي فرص التواصل
الى تسويه بين روسيا واوكرانيا اما
الاجابه فكانت على النحو الاتي 12% قالوا
ان الفرصه كبيره في ظل اخفاق الطرفين في
حسم الصراع العسكريا في حين قال نحو
45% ان الفرص محدوده في ظل تشابك واتساعي
نطاق الصراع بين الطرفين اخيرا يعتقد 43%
ان الفرص منعدمه في ظل تماسك طرفي الصراع
بشروط التفاوض
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
ضمن التحركات الاقليميه والدوليه الرافضه
لانقلاب النيجر اعلنت فرنسا تعليقه
مساعداتها التنمويه لهذا البلد كما عقد
الرئيس ماكرون اجتماعا لبحث تطورات الوضع
في المستعمره السابقه من جهته امهلا مجلس
السلم والامناء التابعه للاتحاد الافريقي
امهل الانقلابيين 15 يوما للعوده الى
سكناتهم والعمل بالنظام الدستوري والافراج
عن الرئيس المتاح به محمد بازوم ومن
المنتظر ان تعقد مجموعه اكواس قمه طارئه
غدا الاحد في ابوجا لمناقشه التطورات
المتسارعه في نيامي واتخاذ قرارات بشانها
حكام النيجر الجدد بالنسبه لهم عهد الرئيس
محمد بازون قد ولا يجتمع رئيس المجلس
القومي لحمايه الوطن بضباط حاليين
والسابقين ووزراء في حكومه لم تعد موجوده
بحكم الامر الواقع وقرارات الانقلابيين
الجلوس الى طاوله واحده لا يعني ان ثمه
اجماعا بشان الانقلاب الذي قاده ونفذه
الحرس الرئاسي للمفارقه كان يفترض ان يعلن
السنادا لمصادر في النيامي من هذه القاعه
ربما وامام بعض الحاضرين هنا قرروا عزل
الرئيس الحرس الرئاسي الذي بات الان الرجل
القوي في البلاد واذا كان من الصعب
والمبكر تحديد من مع ومن ضد الانقلاب داخل
النيجر فخرجيا المساله واضحه منذ البيان
الاول المعلن للاطاحه ببازوم باريس التي
ما تزال تصف الانقلاب بالمحاوله غير
المنتهيه عقد رئيسها ايميويل اجتماعا لبحث
تطورات المستعمره السابقه عنوان الاجتماع
الدفاع والامن القومي في النيجر في احدث
بيان للخارجيه اعلنت فرنسا تعليق
مساعداتها التنمويه ودعمها للموازنه في
النيجر وطلبت بعوده النظام الدستوري في ظل
وجود الرئيس بازوم تنشر فرنسا في هذا
البلد نحو 2500 جندي مكافحه التنظيمات
المتشدده في منطقه الساحل الافريقي
الانقلاب قد يقلب حساباتها مره اخرى وهي
التي اضطرت الى سحب قواتها من مالي
وبوركينا فاسو بعد تغير الحكم فيهما
بانقلابين ايضا بعد بيانات التنديد
والدعوات الى الافراج الفوري عن الرئيس
بازون شدد الاتحاد الافريقي موقفه اكثر اذ
منح مجلس الامن والسلم في الاتحاد
الانقلابيين 15 يوما للعوده الفوريه وغير
المشروطه الى سكناتهم واعاده السلطه
الدستوريه طلب ايضا بالافراج الفوري وغير
المشروط عن الرئيس وجميع المعتقلين وهدد
بمعاقبه الجنات في حال عدم احترامه حقوق
المحتشين صعد الاتحاد الاوروبي موقفه من
الانقلابيين وفي اخر بياناته قال مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد جوزيف بوريل
انه بالاضافه الى وقف دعم الميزانيه فورا
جرى تعليق جميع اجراءات التعاون الامني مع
النيجر لاجل غير مسمى وباثر فوري تهدد
واشنطن باتخاذ نفس الخطوه العقابيه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
كان واضحا التعاون الامني والاقتصادي الذي
يقدر بمئات ملايين الدولارات يعتمد على
استمرار الحكم الديمقراطي والنظام
الدستوري في النيجر تملك الولايات المتحده
قاعدتين عسكريتين في النيجر ولديها اكثر
من الف جندي هناك سلاح تعليق المساعدات
والتعاون بكل اشكاله من عده دول هل سيجدي
مع المجلس الانتقالي العسكري منذ متى غيرت
المواقف الدوليه والاقليميه والقمم
والبيانات شيئا في انقلابات الدول
الافريقيه
الينا من باريس
معهد الاستشراف والامن في اوروبا ومن ابو
جا ديفيد اوتو انديلي مدير مركز جنيف
للامن والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا
مرحبا بكما سيد ايمانويل فرنسا يعني لديها
مخاوف كبيره ولديها مصالح جوهريه
سياسيه اقتصاديه وامنيه ما اكثر ما يقلق
فرنسا في النيجر الان
هو نفسه ما يشغل المجتمع الدولي سواء كانت
ولايه المتحده او اتحاد الاوروبي فخر
مشاهدته كان هناك
تصريحات الرئيس لينك
ورئيس
الاتحاد الافريقي وكل ذلك والان سعيدا
الرئيس
الجزائر
اذا هذا عوده الى التوافق الاراء والى شيء
ومحدد ومهم
الدول الخمسه تشكل مجموعه تسجيل خمسه في
ساحل شاهدوا الكثير من الانقلابات
والنيجر كانت هي الحاله الاستثنائيه تحصل
فيها انتخابات
وبالتالي فان الرئيس
الغرب بشكل عام تعهد
الرئيس بازوم
بتعهدات مهمه بعودته وايضا هو
طبق فعليا وعمليا بعض
[موسيقى]
الخطوات على الارض على سبيل المثال مثلا
سحب الدعم الامني وايضا المالي برايك هل
بامكان الغرب ان يثني الانقلابيين عن
الذهاب الى هذا المسار مع كل هذا الاصرار
على عوده المسار الديمقراطي
لا اعتقدوا ان
هذه المقاربه ستكون مقاربه عمليه ستساعد
على
تخلي
الحكومه العسكريه عن السيطره للحكم لان
هذا الامر قد مر هذه المعارضه قد انتهت
بعد مرور 48 ساعه انا افهم ان الفرنسيين
والدول الاوروبيه الاخرى تقوم بسحب دعمها
لكن هذا امر طبيعي امر طبيعي لانه ليس
هنالك حكومه الان موجوده المجلس العسكري
قام بحل البرلمان وايضا قاموا بايقاف
العمل بالدستور بالتالي
هذه هي اجراءات طبيعيه ونحن التي نشهدها
اعتقد ان ما هو مهم ان نتذكره
ان في هذه المرحله ليس لا يهم عدد
الادانات لا يمكنها ان تصلح الوضع الجيش
قام
باجراء هذا الانقلاب اعتقد ان الخطوه
التاليه يجب ان تكون
باجبار المجلس العسكري على
التبني حكومه انتقاليه لكي يتمكن البلد
نوعا ما من العوده الى المسار الديمقراطي
مثل هذه الرؤيه لا يمكن اعاده عقارب
الساعه الى الوراء مع كل هذا الاصرار
الغربي عن العدول عن هذا الانقلاب وهنا
نسال ما هي حدود التنازلات التي يمكن ان
يقبل بها الغرب يعني الابقاء على هذا
المسار ولكن بتعديلات
اولا هذا الامر لا يتعلق بالغرب هو الذي
حدد
الشروط العوده الى الديمقراطيه هذا امر
يعود للشعب النيجيريا يقرر كيف يعود الى
الديمقراطيه الامر ليس بيد باريس ولا
واشنطن
وبالتالي لابد ايضا من النظر بالانتباع
الكبير الى اجتماع منظمه الامن والتعاون
واهتمام بوساط التي يقوم بها الرئيس ايهاب
رغم صعوبه توصيل لاني ولابد الانتباهي
بشكل كبير الى ذلك والى عندما الدول الدول
الاوروبيه كلها متفقه وتعرف ما هو خطوره
الوضع وكما قلتم لا يمكن العوده الى
الوراء يمكن العوده الى المفاوضات لم
تنتهي الحداد الافريقي اعطى مهله خمسه عشر
يوما
لكي يقوم هذا المجلس انقاذ الوطن للتراجع
عن موقفه
هل يمكن ان يقبل مثلا تقبل الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
يتعامل مع
السلطات الامر الواقع الان في النيجر
بعدما جرى بحدود مثلا بنوع من انواع
التنازلات المعينه او التعديلات او
الاتفاق على مستقبل الرئيس بازون
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا وايضا المانيا
لديها الكثير من
القول اذا ما كان هنالك ربما فرض لقوى
لعقوبات قاسيه على المجلس العسكري الامر
يعود الى ان الولايات المتحده لديها قاعده
قويه جدا في النيجر وايضا فرنسا كذلك
بالتالي يجب ان يكونوا حذرين للغايه في
مساله ضمان انهم لا يخسروا راي العام في
النيجر تذكرون ان
فرنسا قامت اعاده نشر قوتها حوالي قوه
عددها 1,000 جندي
بالتالي فرنسا تريد يجب ان تتحلى بالحذر
من اجل ان لا تخسر دعم الراي العام في
النيجر
شكرا جزيلا لك من ابو جا ديفيد اوتو اندلي
مدير مركز جنيف للامن والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا ومن باريس
معهد الاستشراف والامن في اوروبا
[موسيقى]
للملف السوداني فقد قال مصر عسكري للجزيره
ان الجيش نفذ ضربات جويه على تجمعات لقوات
الدعم السريع كانت تتمركز في كليه النهضه
بحي الصحافه جنوب الخرطوم وسوق صحافه
ومحطه سبعه جنوب الخرطوم مشيرا الى مقتل
عدد من عناصر الدعم السريع كما شهد محيط
سلاح المدرعات التابع للجيش السوداني في
حي جبره جنوب الخرطوم مواجهات عنيفه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع وحسب مصادر عسكريه
تمكن الجيش من صد هجوم لقوات الدعم السريع
كان يهدف للسيطره على السلاح المدرعات
قال الجيش السوداني ان قوات شرطه
الاحتياطيه المركزي وقوات من الجيش بدات
اليوم عمليات تمشيط مشتركه لجيوب من سماهم
متمردي الدعم السريع في سوق ام درمان
واحياء بيت المال والعرب والشهداء الواقعه
وسط المدينه
على الصعيد السياسيه قالت وزاره الخارجيه
السودانيه ان وفد الجيش السوداني الى
مفاوضات جده مع قوات الدعم السريع سيكون
جاهزا للعوده الى طاوله التفاوض متى ما
تمكنت الوساط السعوديه الامريكيه من ازاله
العقبات والمعوقات التي حالت دون مواصله
المباحثات واشارت الخارجيه الى ان قوات
الدعم السريع لم تلتزم بما وقعت عليه في
جده واكدت الخارجيه السودانيه ان قوات
الدعم السريع واصلت احتلال منازل
المواطنين والمرافق العامه وتعطيل الخدمات
مع استمرار عمليات النهب
[موسيقى]
قال اندريه ماك رئيس مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني ان صيغه الرئيس فلودي السلام هي
طريقه الوحيده لانهاء الحرب على حد تعبيره
واضاف يرما كان بلاده تعمل مع شركائها
لتطوير فهما موحد لهذه الصيغه من خلال
انشاء هيكل لتنسيق لتنسيق بين الدول
المعنيه وفي اخر تطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا سجلت الساعات الماضيه تطورا
ميدانيا لافتا تجسد في استهداف المدن
مجددا في كلا الجانبين في الاثناء كشفت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
زخارفا ان موسكو تلقت نحو 30 مبادره سلام
للتسويه عبر قنوات رسميه وغير رسميه منذ
بدء الحرب في فبراير من العام الماضي
بينما تتواصل الحرب سيجالا بين روسيا
واوكرانيا تلوح كييف مجددا بالصيغه التي
طرحها الرئيس فلودي ميلزكي للسلام مع
روسيا رئيس مكتب زيلينسكي وصفت تلك الصيغه
بانها الطريقه الوحيده لانهاء الحرب وان
كيف تعمل مع شركائها لتطوير فهم موحد لها
كان زيلنسكي قد طرحت تلك الصيغه وتتالف من
عشره بنود في قمه مجموعه العشرين
باندونيسيا منتصف نوفمبر الماضي ويروج لها
منذ اذنت اقليميا ودوليا شملت الصيغه عده
نقاط بينها وقف العدائيات وانسحاب القوات
الروسيه واستعاده سياده ووحده اراضي
اوكرانيا دون شروط واطلاق سراح السجنائها
وتامين السلامه النوويه بجانب نقاط اخرى
تتعلق بالغذاء والبيئه
رفضت روسيا الصيغه بشده واعتبرها وزير
الخارجيه
غير مقبوله وان موسكو لن تتحدث مع اي طرف
على اساسها ووصف فكره اخراج روسيا من شرق
اوكرانيا والقرن بانها مجرد وهم واخيرا
قال الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين خلال القمه
الافريقيه الروسيه في سام بوتسبرغ وهو
يعلق على المبادره الافريقيه لانهاء
النزاع مع اوكرانيا ان بلاده مستعده دائما
للتفاوض لكن كيف هي من ترفض في هذه
الاثناء تستعير الحرب على صعد مختلفه
والتطور اللافت الراهن وتجدد استهداف
المدن من قبل الجانبين
تقول اوكرانيا ان القوات الروسيه قصفت
مدينه دونيبرو بصواريخ اسكندر وسقط عدد من
الجرحى وتضررت بعض المباني ومنشات البنيه
التحتيه كما تعرضت مقاطعه روستوف الروسيه
الحدوديه لقصف صاروخي اوكراني واعترفت
روسيا باصابه 15 شخصا جراء انفجار بمقهى
في مدينه تاغان روك بالمقاطعه واعلنت
موسكو احباط محاولتين للقوات الاوكرانيه
للتقدم باتجاه منطقه سفاتوف الجنوبيه وست
محاولات لاستعاده المناطق التي خسرتها
باتجاه اليمن
وعلى وقع الامور المشتعله تفقد الرئيس
زيلينسكي مواقع القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه
في خط الجبهه القريب من بخفوهت بمقاطعه
دونست شرقي البلاد كانت القوات الروسيه قد
سيطرت على باخم مود قبل اشهر ومنذ اذن
تسعى كييف الى استردادها مع غيرها وتقول
روسيا ان هجمات القوات الاوكرانيه باءت
بالفشل
حديث اثر عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
كبير الباحثين في مؤسسات المبادره
الديمقراطيه ومن موسكو المحلل السياسي
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكما اذا
حسب ماريا خروفا المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه وصلت الى تقريبا 30 مبادره منذ
بدايه الحرب حتى الان هل نضجت الظروف لهذه
المبادرات مبادرات السلام كي تبصر النور
مجرد ماليه صغار في التحدث عن ذلك على
شاهدتم اخر تصريح قدمه الرئيس بوتين عندما
كان يتحدث مع القاده الافارقه في سنه
واليوم الرئيس بوتين اجاب على صحف السؤال
من صحفي روسيا والخلاصه هي انه قال ان
روسيا مستعده وجاهلا جاهزا مفاوضات سلام
لكن الامر يتطلب من الطرفين وليس طرف واحد
هذا
فانك الموقف حاليا نجد ان اوكرانيا ليس
لديها اي نيه للدخول في اي مفاوضات مع
روسيا وليس روسيا هي التي تقوم بالهجوم بل
انما اوكرانيا تقوم بالهجوم حاليا واود
ايضا نقول في السنه الماضيه الرئيس الاسكي
الرئيس الاوكراني
رسميا منع اي مفاوضات مع موسكو وبالتالي
نظرا لهذا فاننا قد نعتبر ان اي خطه
الخطه الافريقيه او الصينيه ولكن من ناحيه
العمليه لترجمه ذلك الى حقيقه واقع فان
الجانب الاوكراني على الارجاح لابد عليه
ان يصلوا الى استنتاج بان يفهموا بان لا
يمكن ان تتصارع في هذه الحرب
وبالتالي يبداون بالعمل
الشاق من اجل فتره تسويه تسويه ما بعد
الحرب كل الحرب لابد ان تنتهي ولكن لحد
الان حول ذلك
هل يمكن التفاوض عليها خاصه بان نهايه اي
حرب
هيا في النهايه
ستذهب الى مسار من التفاوض ومبادرات
السلام المقدمه بناء عليها سيذهب الطرفين
للتفاوض وبالتالي الذهاب للسلام هل الامر
ممكن مع صيغه الانسكي
نعم هي
هي ممكنه وقد اظهر هذا الامر السنه
الماضيه عندما قامت اوكرانيا بواساطه
الولايات المتحده وتركيا وافقت على مع
روسيا على مساله اتفاقيه الحبوب لكن مع
حصل شهده العالم باكمله بوتين لم يحترم
وعده هو خرقه انها اتفاق الحبوب التاليه
هذا الان قامت المتحده بوزاره الخارجيه
بتقليل اهميتها هذا الامر لان يوم امس
قال بوتين ان اتفاق الحبوب لن يتم اعاده
العمل به والاكثر من ذلك وما يحاول القيام
به هو خلق الانشقاق بين القاده الاوروبيه
ورشواتهم من اجل ان يتم تصدير الحبوب الى
دول معدوده وتم تذكيرها من قبل
القائد الذي اقترح اقتراحا الاتفاقي سلام
اتقاله اننا لم ناتي لتلقي الهدايا ولتوسل
لكن من اجل توصلي الى سلاما بين روسيا
واوكرانيا ولكن الهجوم المضاد لم يثمر ما
كانت تامل منه اكياس
وهناك عمليه استنزاف ان كان ايضا للجانب
الروسي ولكنها ايضا للجانب الاوكراني
والغرب يتحدث عن كل فعاليه للهجوم مضاد لم
ياتي بنتائج كما يريد هنا ما هو المخرج في
ظل حديث عن مبادرات سلام
المخرج لهذا الوضع ان روسيا يجب ان تسحب
قواتها من اوكرانيا ذكر هذا الامر في شهر
مارس السنه الماضيه
وروسيا بدات بسحب
قواتها عندما الحقت الهزيمه بها ما نرغبه
برؤيته هنا انه يجب ان ننتظر الى نهايه
فصل الصيف والخريف حيث تنتهي الحمله
العسكريه ونرى ايضا
خرقا وكسرا للجسر بين القرب وروسيا بعد
هذا الامر لقد تجبر روسيا على الجلوس على
طاوله المفاوضات يجب على روسيا كبادره حسن
نيه عليها ان تبدا العمل باتفاقيه الحبوب
وايضا
افضل
فيما تبقى من الوقت يعني افاق التفاوض من
هو المعني اكثر بها هل هي روسيا ام
روسيا فعليا واوكرانيا
اول نقطه صفقه
حبوب تحدث عنها الضيف الاوكراني لا علاقه
لها بالتسويه السلميه هذه وهذا موضوع
مختلف تماما علينا نخلط الامور وننسى
الحقائق اذا صفقه الحبوب القصه او موضوع
وقصه السلام قصه اخرى مختلفه الشيء الثاني
ان
ان الضيف الاوكراني تتجنب الحقيقه
لم اسمع اي كلمه من الرئيسكي بانه يستعد
لمفاوضات سلام على خلاف الرئيس سبوتين اذن
ليست روسيا بل هو الجانب الاوكراني هو
الذي جرجر اقدامه
ويرفض
المبادرات تقدمت الدوله الافريقيه والصينة
النقطه رقم ثلاثه الاقتراح بان روسيا
تنسحب ان تعود لعدود 91 يمكن وصلها في
الدبلوماسيه على انها الاقتراح غير عملي
الغير مقبول ويمكن اعتباره لا هو غير
مقبول ولن يقبل وبالتالي ما ان يتلحق
الهزيمه باوكرانيا على ساحه المعارك
سيدركون انه لسنا كاي طريقه امامهم سوى
المفاوضات لكن الامر مازال يحتاج لبعض وقت
لانه ما زال لديهم السلاح والقوى البشريه
وعلى الارجح الرجاح سيوصلنا الى هذه
الحقيقه وادراكها بعد الشيء من الزمن او
فتره من الوقت شكرا لك من الماسك المحلل
السياسي والاستراتيجي بترو بيركوسكي كبير
الباحثين في مؤسسه المبادره الديمقراطيه
شكرا لكم
وصف رئيس الوزراء البولندي ماتيوش
مرافيتسكي الوضع على حدود بلاده بانه
الاكثر خطوره بعد تحرك اكثر من 100
نحو ممري سوالكي وقال ان تحرك تلك القوات
نحو الممر خطوه نحو هجوم اخر على اراضي
بولندا
بعد قليل في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على
ممرس والكي واهميته الاستراتيجيه ونسال
ضيف الحصاد عن المخاوف اتساع الصرا
[موسيقى]
نقلت صحيفه نيور تايمز عن مسئولين
امريكيين قولهم ان اداره بايدن تبحث عن
فيروس تعتقد ان الصين اخفته بعمق داخل
الشبكات التي تتحكم في الكهرباء والمياه
وانظمه الاتصال التي تغذي القواعد
العسكريه في الولايات المتحده ومختلفه
انحاء العالم كما نقلت صحيفه عن مسؤولا في
الكونجرس قوله ان البرنامج الضاري يعد
بمثابه قنبله موقوته يمكن ان تمنح الصين
القدره على قطع او ابطاء عمليات الانتشار
العسكريه الامريكيه وصولا الى احداث خلل
في عمليات الامداد عن طريق قطع الطاقه
والمياه وانظمه الاتصالات عن القواعد
العسكريه وبحسب مسؤولين امريكيين فان
تاثير الفيروس قد يكونوا اوسع بكثير لان
البنيه التحتيه هي ذاتها التي تزود منازل
وشركات المواطنين الامريكيين
في سياق ذاته قالت مجله فوربس في تقريرا
حصري ان البنتاغون يحقق في اختراق داخليا
خطير للاتصالات عبر سبعه عشره منشاه تابعه
للقوات الجويه الامريكيه من قبل احد
مهندسيها وذكرت ان الاداره الامريكيه تلقت
بلاغا من احد المقاولين في قاعده ارنولد
الجويه بان المهندس سرق اجهزه اتصالات
حكوميه ليستخدمها في منزله واشارت فوربس
الى ادله على حدوث خرق محتمل لاتصالات
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكي من
قبل نفس المهندس الذي عمل في القاعده
الجويه واوضحت فوربس ان المفتشين وجدوا
لدى المشتبه فيه خلال دعم المنزل شريحتك
كمبيوتر تحتوي على كلمات مرور ومفاتيح
نظام الكتروني لشبكه راديو قاعده ارنولد
الجويه
انضموا الينا من واشنطن لاند سيموران
ضابطه سابقه في وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه
مرحبا بك معنا خطوره ما كشفت عنه عن هذا
الفيروس المحتمل بانه صيني ويوجد ضمن
النظم شبكات الاتصالات اتصالات المياه
وانظمه الكهرباء وانظمه الاتصالات
اعتقد ان هذا الامر خطير للغايه حقيقه ان
هذا الامر كان موجودا منذ مده كان هنالك
تقارير اوليه لتدخل وقرصنات صينيه
وكان هنالك
محاوله قرصنه لشفره في كمبيوتر في جزيره
غوام حيث هناك قاعده عسكريه امريكيه هناك
الامر يتجه من المحتمل انه قد يتطلب وقتا
اكثر مما
ظهر الان ربما كان موجودا منذ مده وقد
قناه للاستخبارات معرفه به ما الاخطر هو
انه من غير الواضح في هذه المرحله اذا
مكان هذا الفيروس مو وجها الى القواعد
العسكريه الامريكيه ام الى النشاطات
المدنيه لكن في نفس الوقت فان لهذا
الفيروس له امكانيه في ان يكون له نتائج
كارثيه فيما يتعلق بجهود العسكريه الام في
مساله ربما نشاطاتها في مناطق مختلفه مثل
تايوان بالتالي الامر خطير للغايه ويعود
ايضا
للواجهه ايضا لمواجهه خطر خرق داخلي ايضا
الى اي درجه هذا الامر يعني يرفع رايه
حمراء في البنتاجون ويذكرنا بحدث جرى في
ابريل من هذا العام ايضا يعني اذا كنت
تذكرين معي
الذي قام ايضا بتسريبات وثائق سريه جدا
اعتقد ان البنتاغون والاجهزه الاستخبارات
لديها الامور كثيره يجب ان تقلق حولها
هنالك ايضا محاولات الاختراق من الصين
واختراقات الداخليه التي كما قلت قد يكون
لها نتائج كارثيه بالتالي هذا الامر يتم
تفحصه داخليا وخارجيا لكن راينا ما مدى
خطوره هذه الهجومه الهجمات السيبرانيه
عندما نتحرر
باجنحه الشمسيه او السولار وينكس هو الذي
استخدمته الاجهزه الروسيه وايضا كان هنالك
هجمات من مجموعات روسيه اجراميه وايضا
اثرت على تجهيزات الغاز والديزل في الساحه
الغربي كل هذه النشاطات لديها امكانيه
واحتماليه انها تقوم بتعطيل النشاطات
العسكريه والمدنيه في الولايات المتحده
شكرا لك يا السيده ليندسي موران ض ابطه
سابقه في وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
عوده الى تحذيرات بولندا من الوضع على
الحدود الذي تصفه بالاكثر خطوره بعد تحرك
اكثر من مئه مسلح من قوات فاجنر نحو ممري
سوالكي لكن ما اهميه هذا الممر ممرس هو
ممر استراتيجي يبلغ طوله نحو 65 كيلو مترا
ويقع على الحدود بين بولندا
ويربط بين كلنينجراد وبلاروسيا ولطالما
مثل نقطه شائكه بالنسبه لموسكو يشكل هذا
الممر مصدر قلق لانه في حال سيطرت موسكو
عليه ستعزل دول البلطيق الثلاث وهي
ليتوانيا وبولندا وبلاروسيا عن بقيه
الناتو واوروبا بطبيعه الحال اشرنا الى ان
ممارسه والكي يفصل بين اذا بيلاروسيا
وكلينجراد الروسيه التي ترابط فيها قوات
واليات روسيا ضخمه وهذا ينقلنا الى معطى
جديد
تضيف الى اهميه الممر حيث تمثل منطقه
كالينينجراد الروسيه كما نشاهد الواقعه
وسط الاراضي الاوروبيه على سواحل بحر
البلطيق اهميه جيوسياسيه استراتيجيه بالغه
للسلطات في موسكو خصوصا في ظل الحرب على
اوكرانيا وتوسع النيترو اثر ذلك بطلب
فنلندا
والسويد الانضمام الى الحلف نجاه اخرى
يمكن لهذا الممر ان يكون فرصه نيتو
لمحاصره
وخلق التحركات العسكريه الروسيه في بحر
البلطيق ما يضعه في عمق تنافس يشتد مهددا
بالنشوب الصراع المسلح بين الجانبين وبحسب
خبراء فالافضليه العسكريه لروسيا في
ممرسوالكي يكمن ذلك في قدرتها على توفير
القوه الضروريه لاي عمل في هذا الممر
والحفاظ على خطوط امداد سليمه بل وتحريكها
ونشرها بشكل اكثر ثلاث
من الاكثر قلقا هولندا فهي قلقه من احتمال
امتداد حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اليها
وبولندا هي عضو سابق في حلف وارسو كما انه
عضو كامل في النيتو منذ عام
1999 ويقول رئيس الوزراء البولنديين
مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
اقتربت من مدينه غرودنا في بيلاروسيا
بالقرب من الحدود البولنديه وبدات بولندا
في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر نقل اكثر من الف
جندي الى شرقها وسط تصاعد المخاوف من ان
يؤدي وجود مقاتل فاينر في بيلاروسيا الى
زياده التوتر على طول حدودها في تلك
المنطقه وبحسب
مسؤول في وزاره الداخليه الليتوانيه تنظر
بولندا
في اماكن في امكان اغلاق حدودهما مع
بيلاروسيا اذا شكلت مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه
تهديدا لهما على كل الاضاءه اكثر حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من اكسفورد الدكتور
فرانكي
الخبير العسكري والضابط السابق في
المخابرات العسكريه البريطانيه
سيد فرانك مرحبا بك معنا اذا المخاوف
البولنديه هل لها ما يدعمها على الارض في
هذا الشريط الحدودي
اسعدت مساء
البولنديين يقلقون من شيئين اولهما
امكانيه ان مرتزقه قد يدخلون بولندا عن
طريق
الحدود وبالتالي يفكرون بغلق الحدود بين
بيلاروسيا وفولندا
هذا اعتقد هو قلق مشروع
وهناك امكانيه لتسلل يقوم بهؤلاء الافراد
وامكانيه ما يمكن نسميه
اعمال ارهابيه ولكن ليس هناك اي امكانيه
اطلاقا وهذا هو الخطر الثاني ان نقوم ان
يهدد مرتزقه فاكنار
الرابط او الممر السؤال الكيوي يسيطر عليه
فاي مرتزقه واي قوه عسكريه حتى لو كانت
مسلحه او مدرعه ست دمر على ارجاع خلال
ساعه واحده من قبل القوات الجويه
وهذا محاوله الدخول
ما هي المعطيات المتوفره الان على الارض
التي تستدعي كل هذا القلق البولندي
وجيه للغايه اعتقد ان هذا الامر هو
السياسي وليس عسكري او هو خطر سياسي وليس
خطر عسكري في الاسبوع الماضي الرئيس من
بيلاروسيا
اشارت بشكل عابر وان كان ذلك ليس بعذرا بل
كان مقصودا تماما
بان الضيوفه من منظمه
قد يفكرون بالتدخل
في
مطارات تجهيز ومحطات القطارات التجهيز
الموجوده
ويبدو ان بولندا ترد على ذلك ولذلك نجهز
ان كيف ان السيارات العسكريه البولنديه
بدات توجه الى الحدود وذلك
لتوفير نوع من الامن للبولنديين وليس
لمواجهه اي خطر عسكري حقيقي الخطر الذي قد
يكون على يد مجموعات صغيره او افراد
ارهابيه وليس بهجوم عسكري ولكن اعين روسيا
ايضا تراقب هذا الممر الحيوي بالنسبه لها
جدا خاصه مع وجود كالينينجراد في هذه
المنطقه التي ترى بانها هي جيو استراتيجيه
وحيويه لها ولكن يحاول ان تعزلها وتطويقها
فيها هنا السيد فرانك برايك كيف ستكون
الخطوات الروسيه في ظل هذا التوتر
اذا روسيا
قد وضعت
الكثير من قواتها العسكريه في جاليني هي
المنطقه الخريطه
وحسب علمي ليس لديهم اي قدرات هجوميه هناك
يمكن ان تمكنهم من مواجهه او تحدي القوات
الاسبانيه والامريكيه والكنديه
والبريطانيه وخاصه القوات البولنديه ايضا
التي ستواجههم له سيتلحق بهم في وقت
الاتفاق قصيره جدا هذا واضح
لذلك انا اقول هذا مجرد تحرك القوات
البولنديه هي رساله سياسيه وليس عمليه ردع
عسكري اذا برايك الناتو فورا يتحرك في حال
حدوث اي خلل في هذه المنطقه هذا الممر
لو كان هناك اي تحركات عسكريه
روسيه في ذكر المنطقه فذلك سيؤدي الى
تفعيل
الماده الخامسه من اتفاقيه التي تقول
الهجوم على اي بلد في النيتو هجوم على
الكل وودناك احتمال اخر ان روسيا يمكن ان
تتبرع من اي هجوم يقوم به فاقلار ومرصقتها
على فيه هجوم على اي مطار او اي هدف اخر
[موسيقى]
هندسه التعامل معهم
روسيا فعلت ذلك سابقا في سوريا في الواقع
ففي سوريا القوات الامريكيه قوات
الامريكيه تسببت في اكثر قتيل في مرتزقه
فاقنر الروس والدوله الروسيه انكرت حتى
وجودهم هناك وبالتالي
الخبير العسكري والضابط السابق في
المخابرات العسكريه البريطانيه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
احوال الطقس والتغير المناخيه يتاثر بها
الجميع يقول علماء ان الصين تتعرض منذ
اشهر لظروف مناخيه قاسيه ودرجات حراره غير
معتاده في بعض المناطق تفاقمت بسبب تغير
المناخ وقبل ساعات وضعت السلطات الصينيه
جزءا من البلاد في حاله تاهب قصوى بما في
ذلك العاصمه بيجين ومنطقتها مع توقع امطار
غزيره في اعقاب الاعصار دكتور الذي يضرب
الاطراف الطرف الاخر من البلاد حاله
الانذار الاحمر تشمل منطقه شاسعه يعيش
فيها مئات الملايين في بدايه يوليو الجاري
حطمت بجين ومنطقتها درجات الحراره
القياسيه
معها فوق اربعين درجه مئويه وللتذكير
الاحتباس الحراري الناجم عن انبعاثات
الغازات الناتجه عن الانشطه البشريه يزيد
من شده وتواتر الظواهر الجويه المتطرفه
مثل الاعاصير وموجات الحر والامطار
الغزيره والجفاف وفقا لخبراء نتمنى
السلامه للجميع ختام الحصاد شكرا لكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]